welcome to film theory reaction from the
two best homeless people on the youtubes
that's why i wear glasses to kind of
offset some of the homeless look that i
naturally possess
this guy reads it's the branding though
it's the brand homeless bra a very
specific market now the homeless
population is on the rise we're trying
to do more sponsorships that will tend
to
them so spider-man no way homeless am i
right anyway if you're offended by that
um you're not homeless the homeless
people aren't even watching
i can't
go
go give some money or buy somebody a
sandwich let's watch this today
apparently uh they got some [ __ ] to
prove here i need to i need to go back
and see what their last theory was i
kind of forgot it spider-man saved no
one spa three spider-man no way home
theories you know we gotta check this
out
[Music]
okay let's be real spider-man no way
home was a blast if nothing else you
have to admire a movie that brought
together three separate franchises
spanning 20 years sure i agree it was
impressive and all but that was always
the uh it was always the end game for
the mcu from the very beginning but here
no one could have seen this one coming
just absolutely so much fun which means
that now we have to rip this thing to
shreds because that ending man we have
gotta talk about it well the movie was
great and all peter parker's final wish
left me with a lot of questions it seems
like i'm not the only one i mean there's
a guy have a birth certificate a social
security card what happens with all the
videos and news reports about him being
spider-man so what did old tommy holland
actually wish for in the final moments
of the movie and what does that actually
translate to based on every clue that we
see in the film's final moments and more
importantly what does it mean for the
future of this character and this
franchise
that might be spider-man aiming to
answer today
[Music]
let's see if they can answer this if
anybody can i am interested in hearing
how they can answer this because even
the screenwriters came out i forget what
newspaper article was but they were
saying that they didn't even have an
answer for a lot of this that they they
realized they could go down this whole
rabbit hole that they just focused
solely on the emotion and not some of
the logistics regarding it that really
shows like that's interesting
i guess it works but that's a very very
risky way to play it that's a bold way
of putting it too especially
so you get these videos hello internet
welcome to film theory where i use my
peter tingle each and every week to spot
and solve lore mysteries obviously
okay so spiderman no way home really
needs no introduction at this point it
seems like everyone in the world has
seen this thing probably has actually
except the people in the philippines
weekend of all time of any movie ever
that is insane in fact it only took that
one single weekend to make the highest
grossing movie of 2021. after a year
where theaters were struggling to find
their footing the old web head proved
that people were willing to come back
provided you have a huge ip pay off one
of cinema's biggest cliffhangers and tap
into 20 years of build up nostalgia you
know no biggie but this movie really
does have it all lots of bad guys come
together toby maguire getting his back
cracked great power great responsibility
all that stuff really solid across the
board but gotta be honest here anytime
you tamper with multiverse you're gonna
be getting some questions from lore
nerds like me and this movie leaves open
some big ones questions that i aim to
definitively multi-matter today or you
know as definitive as i can until they
retcon something to fit the ongoing
narrative that they're looking to tell
first and foremost why are we only
seeing the villains as a reminder the
entire premise of the movie kicks off
when peter parker asks doctor strange to
cast a spell that makes everyone forget
that he's spider-man after peter tampers
with the spell one too many times it
breaks the fabric of reality opening the
door for villains like lizard and dr
otto octavius to come through from other
universes because as the movie tells us
they knew the spider-man peter parker
connection at least most of them did
prompting our first major discussion
here electro is a bit here we go at this
point since the amazing spider-man 2 max
dylan never explicitly makes the peter
parker spider-man connection in fact it
seems like no way home acknowledges this
there's even a joke about it where
electro upon seeing andrew garfield's
face at the end of the movie says that
he'd assumed that peter parker was gonna
be black the entire time so is that just
the writers being sloppy so they can fit
in a miles morales joke or are they
actually playing some level of 4d chess
that we mere nerds aren't privy to well
there are two possible ways to explain
elektro's presence both of which require
a fair amount of squinting to make work
first we hear no already scored
and this is a direct quote from the
movie that i can't play for obvious
reasons he was stuck in the grid exactly
that's exactly what's going with this
yeah he dies now this isn't exactly true
if you go back to the source material
electro was actually in a power grid
specifically a hydroelectric power grid
and uh i know science wasn't your
strongest suit hollywood so this might
come as a shock to you but electricity
is different than the internet i know i
know i was just as blown away as you are
but i guess if you're assuming that he's
absorbing electricity he saw a series of
tubes
then you could say that max got the info
through accessing peter's online data
maybe
like i said it's a pretty weak sauce
explanation the other angle here and
this is the one that i think is
canonical to the story and also works
with the whole i thought you'd be black
joke is that max does know spider-man's
name is peter he just doesn't know his
face in the final fight elektra is
knocked unconscious after playing the
itsy bitsy spider on the power that gwen
comes out or gobbling decisions gwen
stacy arrives and calls out to peter at
which point we smash cut to electro
becoming alert and ready to attack again
when i say you turn that power on you
turn it on no matter what peter so that
definitely explains how electro knows
that spider-man's name is peter but i
think that there's still a missing piece
here i mean him knowing his name is
peter's not really anything it's just
the name it's like it's such a god it's
a common american name peter it's saying
that it's just because he knows the name
peter doesn't mean he knows peter parker
in the face or anything at all
which peter out of all of new york city
this would be you know he knew that
peter snuck into you know ozcorp that
one day in the first movie and then he
was like all about it you know he kept
track of him that's my fan theory ah
you're just one of those girls just
justifies everything it can't be a plot
hole otherwise it's not the best i think
that there's still a missing piece here
and that's peter's best friend harry who
breaks electro out of captivity to help
him take care of spider-man i'm harry
osborn i want to make you a demon you
want
at this point in the movie harry knows
that peter and spider-man share some
sort of connection you took his picture
you know him harry most likely tells all
of this to electro after he breaks him
out so when max hears the name peter
from gwen he's able to make that final
connection to peter parker harry's
friend that he was told about oh boy
there you go screenwriters i saved your
butts on that one something tells me
that no one really intended all of that
but it does manage to work out when you
read between the lines nah i still think
it's a plot hole no it's definitely plus
that's a lot of leaps and bounds that
nearly unconscious electro would have to
put together but here's peter instantly
just
peter parker hair superheroes we're
talking about must be that one he
doesn't know for sure if anything he's
working off of a film theory at that
point
i guess it does it doesn't bother me
either way that's the thing i'm hung up
on i'm just glad he's in the movie no
i'm more interested in the bigger
question why only the villains why don't
we see anyone else come through here
couldn't afford him
best friends in the sam raimi trilogy
mary jane knows peter's identity all too
well go get him tiger and in the amazing
spider-man gwen stacy treats it like
it's the most casual thing in the world
consider coming in through the lobby the
best friends in these movies also tend
to know the harry osborns from both
universes know peter's secret first
we'll see who's behind the mask
so was this just a decision made out of
convenience or is there an actual
in-universe explanation for it well
believe it or not but this one actually
lines up pretty well with the lore i
don't know again if this was intentional
or not but as dr strange prepares his
magic peter requests that his girlfriend
his best friend and aunt may all get
exempted from the spell so m james
they're skeptical of that one removes
them from the magic to try and meet
peter's request however when the whole
thing goes haywire and people who knew
peter's identity start crossing over
those people are still eliminated as
such all the girlfriends best friends
and ants aren't included and therefore
don't cross over into the mcu was it
intentional no probably not is it a cool
coincidence that helps explain the
rationale for that part of the movie
yeah i think so one of the opposites at
all just kind of glosses over that i
thought was interesting to think about
was the implication of curing all of
these characters the whole second act of
the movie is peter sacrificing and
losing everything including ant-may to
try and cure these villains working
under the assumption that he's saving
their lives and giving them a second
chance in their own universes except uh
no nope that is decidedly not true the
sandman doesn't die in his movie so kind
of a lost cause there same thing with a
lizard who already is transformed back
into a human by the end of his movie so
redundancy is redundant that leaves
electro and green goblin neither of whom
want to be cured which opens a big old
can of ethical worms about forcing a
cure on individuals that don't want to
be cured but worst of all perhaps
who if you actually look back at the
original movie wouldn't be saved at all
in no way home he says that he's
portaled over into tom holland's reality
in the middle of a battle against
spider-man specifically he says quote
spider-man was trying to stop my fusion
reactor so i stopped him i had him by
the throat and then i was here one teeny
tiny problem with that by the time doc
has spider-man by the throat and
spider-man 2 his fusion reactor is
already seconds away from exploding it
is far beyond the point of saving the
good doctor himself is mere seconds away
from his own redemption at this point
listen to me now
seriously doc ock already makes the
decision to turn good and sacrifice
himself so tom holland's help with a
fixed neural implant
just a meaningless gesture for something
that was gonna happen anyway in short
this whole movie was extraneous because
you either don't change any character's
outcome or you just cure people who
don't want to be cured in the first
place sorry about your sacrifice aunt
may it doesn't look like you did much
good but hey at least you got to say the
iconic line that was a big part of where
i felt it was kind of lackluster with
doc by the time he's you know cured in
um i don't know why i air quoted it he
is cured except he still has the
tentacles attached to here he's
augmented yeah he's better i'm just an
extension of myself now i have my final
form but when he comes back to his human
self that is not controlled by the
desires of the tentacles right it did
hit me like this even on the first time
watching like well that's okay i feel
like we just watched a less interesting
exact village going back to yourself
according to this movie you were all
these seconds away of being that already
yeah the whole plot hole with him going
back to it what they proved here was
exactly what a lot of us were already
kind of speculating yeah right because
you just basically took him for a side
quest moments before his inevitable
death because of the sacrifice he chose
to make of his own volition but they
don't say when green goblin got pulled
right they don't specify that in the
movie i don't think so he doesn't show
up looking like he's going to fight
peter parker yeah and rubble and whatnot
so yeah it seems like he got plucked the
earliest maybe out of all of that yeah
yeah yeah except for uh lizard i mean
yeah they don't say when lizard gets
plucked i feel like they completely
forgot all about what lizard was like
i think they did a lot of rewrites in a
small amount of time and when they
arrived at a good idea they really
didn't have all the time in the world to
go back and like script supervisor does
this match these old movies from 10 20
years ago i forget it let's just go with
the emotions of peter i was thinking
what they could have done to make salmon
more interesting is justify the choice
to keep him in sand other than learning
the behind the scenes facts that they
couldn't get thomas hayden church to be
on set they could have said like they
have to cure him because he is stuck in
this form now yeah it would have been so
much more history than i'm like all
right how do you justify why he looks
like this the whole movie yeah he's not
a bad guy and then it's like oh off
screen has he been living some kind of
frankenstein story all over again with
like this inescapable verse now yeah
because he doesn't leave cure or exactly
becoming a hero he just ends on a good
note peter powers yeah i mean he ends on
a note of like you forgive me peter good
we cried it out
everyone's crying i respect you peace
but now the big one the ending wish at
the end of the movie the green goblin
uses a pumpkin bomb to destroy the deus
box machina causing reality to shred and
even more entities to try and cross over
into tom holland's universe dr strange
tries to repair the rift but it's just
too much he can't contain it so with no
other option peter makes one final
sacrifice he asks strange to make the
world forget about peter parker now i've
rewatched this
archive which is exactly how it's
transcribed they're here because of you
what if everyone forgot who i was
they're coming here because of me right
because i'm peter parker so i love this
act
please put this on like audible or some
[ __ ]
me that would mean every matpat
would have no memory of you would be as
though you never existed and it works
the rift gets repaired and the world no
longer knows the identity of spider-man
hooray but it comes at the cost of mj
ned happy and all the others have no
clue who peter is so it's just a simple
memory wipe spell right what's so
complicated to understand about that
well if only it were that simple as
peter and disney are more than happy to
remind us of repeatedly throughout the
movie peter is the most famous person in
the world at this point because mysterio
outed him as the identity of spider-man
and he did this in the form of a video
did that video get wiped away by the
spell sure let's assume that it was but
then what about all the other physical
evidence of peter
before the big climax peter takes a
selfie video that gets broadcast out to
the world does that disappear too or his
text messages to mj or flash's book are
those all just gone what about his
application to mit the simple answer
here would be that the spell dusted all
of those things too all physical traces
of peter parker just poof away like
doctor strange said it'll be as though
you never existed except yet again it's
not that clear cut we see in the final
scenes of the movie that mj is wearing
the broken black dahlia necklace that
peter gave her in the previous movie in
addition we learned that both ned and mj
have gotten into mit something that
peter had a direct hand in earlier in
the film so it seems like his physical
actions have had some sort of memory on
the way that's a good point it was a
great one
so maybe peter's just gone then right
everything he touched and altered up
that point stays but anything with the
name peter parker on it's just dusted
away or maybe people can't recognize it
one hand we see peter studying for his
geds for those who don't know the ged
here in the us is a test that allows you
to show that you have high school level
skills by taking it and passing it
functions pretty much the same way as a
diploma so the fact that he's taking it
implies either a that his academic
record has been erased as part of the
spell or b he isn't returning to finish
the school year again most likely
because he no longer has a student
record but on the other hand we see
peter get himself an apartment this
implies that he has to have himself some
level of an identity as well as a fairly
decent credit score does anyone who's
ever tried to get an apartment can tell
you you need a social security number
and a history of income to be able to
lease from a landlord where would his
income come from that's huge one of all
the conflicting evidence we have none
perhaps is as confusing as his
interactions with happy at ant-may's
grave when peter asks how he knew her
happy replies through spider-man so
happy knows spider-man but again not
peter parker how could that possibly
make any sense because happy knows may
not have so much amnesia spider-man is
connected to peter parker without the
link of peter parker there's no way for
happy to meet may and yet somehow under
the arbitrary rules of the spell he does
apparently know her which then prompts
the question does that mean mj under the
memory spell remembers being
spider-man's girlfriend because again
she knows spider-man but she doesn't
know peter same thing with ned does he
know that he's spider-man's guy in the
chair so taking all the evidence and
questions into account i think there's
only one way to explain all of this this
spell doesn't erase peter parker from
existence it just erases people's memory
of him and along with that erases any
physical thing that would be considered
or connected to a memory of him yeah
yeah
the
thing that he's explicitly done those
all remain it's a difference of
qualitative versus quantitative actions
which is pretty confusing so let me
explain with some examples mysterio's
video claiming that he's being attacked
by spider-man that still exists because
it was tied to an action that was being
done by spider-man but the part where he
calls out peter parker that now is gone
because it would be dependent on
mysterio knowing peter
flash's book gone
again it's based on flash's relationship
and memories with peter parker meanwhile
peter's bank account and social security
number those would remain earning money
and putting it into a bank or being
given a social security number are
physical acts that don't hinge on the
memory or identity of peter parker just
like giving a physical necklace to mj
she has the necklace but i would guess
she doesn't remember where she got it
from those actions exist separate from
the identity of peter basically when
people see his name they'll just think
of him as some random anonymous person
like we see mj do in the coffee shop
that is actually the best explanation i
have heard absolutely
i still feel like because what was the
phrase it was using qualitative versus
quantitative yeah qualitative yeah
using that theory it would line up the
best i still feel like it would it
messes with time in some way though it
messes with the past because there's got
to be some like very specific gaps in
memory that are forming due to this yeah
absolutely because there's also a lot of
off-screen memories that we obviously
were not made privy to certain scenes
that involve like very direct memories
with peter parker and aunt may and happy
in the same room
so are there times where happy remembers
helping out spider-man but forgets every
time he was interacting with peter like
all the events in london yeah does he
just have tons and tons of gaps yeah
dude everyone has to blur where peter
used to be still create some like gaps
for sure if we are going off of this one
regret it it's the best one i've heard
so far it has a good cause and effect
kind of balance just there are too many
whole there are too many directions
holes can come out of this choice yeah
yeah it does the most to patch up the
most holes but it still doesn't patch
them all up because they would explain
too when ja when they come back to jay
jonah and he's like spider-man's still a
betis but they don't know who he is yeah
at the end of it all so explain that
at the same time i am so left here
scratching my head going but with the
way the brain works if you really mess
some people up too yeah causality what
then would this mean for the series well
if i'm right it would mean that both mg
and ned shouldn't remember their
interactions with spider-man to both of
them he was peter parker first and when
they're helping spider-man they're
really helping peter so all of those
memories have got to go happy meanwhile
is able to fall into the opposite bucket
his relationship with peter started
through the identity of spider-man and
while he certainly grew to love the boy
behind the mask the root of that
relationship was the secret identity
thus allowing him to remember aunt may
and chalk those memories up to
spider-man's influence likewise
spider-man should still be able to
continue on as an avenger but here no
one will know his real name making the
eventual reunion with the guardians of
the galaxy real awkward who are you
we're the avengers man but to me what's
probably most interesting about all this
is how it relates to the vulture as you
might recall he's the biggest dangling
threat in the series the only one who
knows spider-man's identity and who
keeps getting teased as pulling together
a sinister six this is that on you
it's on our
little spider friend i've got some boys
on the outside would love to meet him in
fact he's so important that he's being
used to market the upcoming morbius
movie hey uh dr mike you and i should
stay in touch leaving many to question
whether morbius is now a part of the mcu
and sony's response thus far has been
yesent
no no he's not this is all just a fake
out by the rules that we've just gone
over the vulture wouldn't know peter's
secret identity the scene in the current
homecoming would be a forgotten memory
as such all of the teases from both
morbius and tom holland's spider-man
movies should ultimately amount to
nothing then moments in trailers like
this are just more instances of movie
studios pulling boners that's a ralph
boner for those of you who don't get the
reference you're
ralph
boner
boner all of it fake outs to sell
tickets
hey guys starting up this video i just
got to ask though what exactly is matpat
implying by saying that this is a fake
out because i get that vulture would no
longer know the identity
of spider-man so it makes it not as
weighty i suppose but at the same time
still is kind of a big deal because
vulture ultimately
uh has still a vendetta towards
spider-man he developed this vendetta
against him
before he ever learned that peter parker
really is him so
i'm not sure what the fake out is really
implying i was watching it back and i'm
like wait a minute i'm a little bit lost
here let's clarify no way home a lot of
seeming gaps in the plot that just
squeak by getting solved if you look at
them deep enough well done screenwriters
you've escaped me this time which leaves
us then with a single spiderman who has
literally no history what a nice clean
slate to start a brand new trilogy on
one might call it a reboot of sorts and
wait who was it that predicted that by
whatever means wanda maximoff zaps in
during the post-credits scene to set us
up for the multiverse of madness this
story is going to wrap up in such a way
that well there can be a path forward
for tom holland's peter parker he can
also be soft rebooted i guess sometimes
even a blind squirrel finds a nod but
you guys are always ready to pat
yourselves on the film theory and
cuts who is matt patting yourself on the
back when you get something right i
think people who do breakdowns they have
to do that they do because it takes a
lot to break these yeah
it's so much wrong though when they get
it right you gotta point it out you have
to risk your credibility
i always point it out for me yeah i
guess something right i'm seeing that
all the time with the morbius thing on
the poster
i'm like i said this a while ago now
everyone now everyone's new thumbnails
or hey that that poster in the morbius
is probably andrew garfield i said that
before it was kind of obvious i said
that before any comment ever said it i
totally did i beat everyone i beat
everyone first person i've ever thought
of man and you guys give me no credit
yeah where do you get off yeah what the
hell man i definitely wasn't the first
although i can't think of someone who
said it before i had the thought well
there you go guys subscribe to film
theory click that notification bell hit
that like button we will thwip you guys
soon but before that pic
rosa parra rosa parra it's a new year so
happy new year to you and you know what
as much as we've been calling you the
lady stark of our patreon page for this
long if there was a new year wish i
could have for you
it was that
we could erase the identity of your
children
i just know
that that would just save you so much
money oh yeah and so much stress you'd
be able to produce
twice maybe three times as many reviews
you can never stop watching movies if
your kids were just in your home and
then you called the cops and said
police uh there are three homeless
children living waters at my home police
show up no record of them they get
shipped off to the orphanage best part
is you forgot who they are too so now
you have
no guilt plausible deniability shame
you're scot-free at that point yeah i'm
gonna i'm able to get in touch with some
wizard of sorts to help the world forget
about who your children are you're not
even gonna remember to thank me cause
you're gonna forget about the whole
ordeal yeah and i'm gonna be sitting
here smiling
not knowing why because i will forgotten
them too
that's how the spell works that's how
the world ends no i'm just kidding i
love you and i want your children to be
yeah kids are the best kids the best in
the world i'm just joking don't let them
watch this video please i'm sorry